are you pretty much religiously
following the rules of screenwriting
you're not like bringing in conflict an
hour into something I you know I having
worked at the agency in red so many
scripts I feel like I have a good grasp
of structure and storytelling I read any
book that I can find about screenwriting
and I revisit books that i love about
screenwriting especially if I'm about to
start a project so I think the short
answer is no I don't think that I'm
breaking many rules now if you asked me
am i breaking rules of story concept
maybe because I'm I try to write things
that are different or new or things that
are just fascinating to me but in terms
of rules screenwriting rules i mean i
think those rules are in place for a
reason you know we've been telling
stories for you know since we were you
know old enough to communicate so i
think that I'll always follow that the
the outline of right or sorry that I
will always follow the general rules of
storytelling I don't think that there's
any necessary reason to break them
you